hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar putting
serological sars cov2 testing into
context
i'm alexis krauss of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labberts
and brought to you by bio-rad
laboratories
to learn more about our sponsor please
visit their website at biorad.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation to
do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i would like to now welcome and
introduce our speakers for today
dr eduardo grebe staff scientist at the
talent
research institute dr veronica lutzi
medical director research and clinical
trials at tri-core research
institute and dr sarah wheeler assistant
professor
at the university of pittsburgh medical
center department of pathology
welcome everyone we are happy to have
you dr wheeler you may now begin
your presentation
thank you for that kind introduction my
name is dr sarah wheeler and i'm going
to be talking a little bit about how
we're using serologic testing for stars
cov2 currently
in the clinical laboratory so first just
a little
overview of what we mean when we're
talking about first kobe 2 serologic
testing
so what are we measuring we're measuring
the body's immune response or antibodies
that are being created against both the
vaccine
and sars kobe 2. specifically against
some of the antigens or four
four key antigens that are present in
sars kov2
so you can see here at the very top of
the screen receptor binding domain
is one of those antigens that we use
that's present in both
vaccine and disease and is actually
what's required to be able to get the
virus into cells and so it correlates
quite well with neutralizing antibodies
the other two antigens that we use are
actually two subunits of the spike
protein
representing the c and n terminals of
that protein and their s1
spike one and s2 spike two and those are
present in both vaccine and disease
and again when i refer to vaccine uh in
this presentation i'll be referring to
uh as of april 2021 the usa eua vaccine
uh and then finally the fourth is
nucleotide uh which is a protein present
inside
the thyroscopy ii um uh envelope
and that's present in disease only it's
not currently present in any of the
vaccines
and so if if a patient comes up positive
for antibodies against nucleic acid it's
indicative of
exposure to sars kobe 2. with any of the
other antigens s1 s2
or rbd the patient could have been um
vaccinated
or exposed to vars kov2
so what does it what does serology look
like now as we move into this
post-vaccine world things have gotten a
little more complicated when we look at
serology
so we're still seeing a lot of cases
come through from infection prevention
so we have to figure out when to
to remove droplet precautions and
generally speaking
10 to 14 days patient should no longer
be contagious but in some of our
much more complex patients that's not
necessarily the case so serology can
help us in
in those decisions and we also have many
cases when we're ready to transfer
someone to a group living facility
their np swap comes back and is
unexpectedly rna positive for such kobe
2 and then we need to try to figure out
is this patient so contagious can we
transfer them or is that putting others
at risk
uh then we also have a lot of cases
where we're looking at symptoms of
infection in the setting of a vaccine
vaccination history so is it an issue
that
the patient does not respond
sufficiently to the vaccine um was it a
pre-existing underlying infection
um trying to to figure that out and then
also
differential and delayed diagnosis which
we'll talk about this later
so for infection prevention as well as
infection in the setting of vaccination
history
one of the things that that we're trying
to do is to use serology as a surrogate
marker for immunity or for
contagiousness
and here in a really nice study done by
room camp and edol
uh they looked at over 600 patients
where they had paired to nasal slugs
and serum and they looked at along the
y-axis
the probability of positive virus
culture
so if you can culture virus from the
nasal swab we take that as a
surrogate for contagiousness but you
would still be contagious if that's
culturable
and then along the x-axis you can see
the serum neutralizing antibody titer
and
those are antibodies that can actually
prevent infection with starch kobe 2 and
an in vitro system
uh and when we look at that as you have
increasing neutralizing antibody tires
the ability to culture virus goes down
which gives us some indication that
when your body's producing antibodies
you're less likely to be contagious
so then the next step is we have in the
laboratory
binding antibody assays we don't test
specifically for neutralizing antibodies
so we want to see what the correlation
there is at a high level so along the
y-axis what you'll see here is the euro
immune igg elisa it was one of the first
elisa's
available during the pandemic and then
along the x-axis you'll see the prnt 50
neutralization assay which is um kind of
one of the gold standard acids that
we've been using for stars cov2 and you
can see that there's a reasonable
correlation between
finding antibodies and neutralizing
antibodies that as you have more
neutralizing antibodies
finding antibody od ratio does in fact
increase
and so this has been very helpful to our
infection preventionists in determining
if a patient has um finding antibodies
that
uh they are less likely to be contagious
and one of the other places that we're
really seeing a lot of utility in the
clinic
is in this differential or delayed
diagnosis and i'd like to share just one
case that came
across my desk in january about this so
this patient's been completely
de-identified
so we're calling her jane today and she
was a 50 year old female she came in
uh again in january of 2021 presenting
with shortness of breath with any type
of exertion she couldn't even walk down
the hall
and she had a past medical history
reasonably expensive for subglottic
stenosis
with multiple interventions uh and she
came in at grade
three so as you can see here to the
right um subglottic stenosis is really a
narrowing of the airways
and grade three is very severe so she
was between 75
and 99 um of airway occlusion
and immediate surgery was scheduled for
the next morning
when they took her in to do all of her
uh pre-surgical testing her
pre-operative stars kobe 2 rna and
p-swab was positive
uh so this is january 2021 and she uh
said that she had
a history of coping 19 exposure at
thanksgiving when her college-age son
came home
but she was never tested she stayed home
she quarantined for the
amount of time she had some mild
symptoms but the
crux of the matter was the covid19 is a
serious contraindication for this
particular surgical intervention
so we needed to really try to tease out
the difference between a january
infection and a november infection and
since we had no
actual testing history to say yes she
was in fact positive at that time
uh we needed to look at other options so
in the
the chart below all of the charts have
some inaccuracies
right now in this particular chart we're
looking at the the blue line which is um
np np swab pcr positive
you can see that people can be positive
for weeks and months after
uh infection and after they're really
infectious uh and their body's still
clearing
clearing the virus and if we look at the
green dotted lines uh slightly to the
right that's the
the increase of igg against sarsakovi ii
and so we can that can occur anywhere
from
a few days to a few weeks after
infection so if she has reasonable
levels of igt then we can
um in infer that the infection is not an
acute infection that has not recently
happened
um it was likely from her her
thanksgiving infection
and so it did turn out that uh she was
highly reactive by serology she was
actually above
the the measurable range of our in-house
neurology assay at the time
um so she was able to successfully have
her surgery and intervention
uh which was was very exciting for her
and
since recovers very well so a few other
things that we're anticipating uh as we
continue in this
uh mass vaccination uh one of the things
that has come up
and there was a lot of talk about it
last summer and it's
we're seeing some revival of it um is
this idea of immunity passports that we
test everyone
to see if they have antibodies and for
many reasons we decided that was a bad
idea and i think we will continue to
think that's a bad idea so
we're not really anticipating seeing a
test everyone
um scenario necessarily but there are a
lot of lessons that we can pull from
hepatitis b and mmrv
uh so just as a reminder hepatitis b uh
is a very effective vaccine anywhere
from 80 to 100 percent it's a bit
population dependent
um it's a series of vaccines it's not
just a single vaccine
and one of the things that's interesting
about hepatitis b is that
um when we test for the antibody
response when we test serious logic
titers
serologic titers disappear quite quickly
after successful vaccination
however the cellular immunity of the
patient persists and so when they are
re-re-challenged with hepatitis b they
will immediately
see an increase in their antibodies as
we can see with booster if we give a
booster vaccine
so the the fact that their antibody
titers wane
significantly to below detectable levels
with time
really is not a reflection of how
successful the hepatitis b
series has been on the flip side mmrb um
well mmr is the vaccine that many people
have gotten in two doses
um is 97 effective against measles 88
against monks and those titers do tend
to stay in detectable levels
even through adulthood um and levels
that are indicative of
uh continuing immunity so how we
currently use these serologies is
reflective of how we're likely to be
using sarcoidosis in the future
so for many of you who are probably in
healthcare you may recall that you
probably had your hepatitis b
titers checked as you entered a new
hospital or new healthcare setting
so in the upper right hand corner here
we can see that um people
moving into high prevalence situations
whether that's healthcare or building
facilities
will often have their tires verified
to ensure that they still have immunity
um in the upper left we can also
see that often when when people are
traveling to places that are perhaps
endemic for a particular disease or
uh where again prevalence might be
higher they're going to be tested
to see if they need re-vaccination
against any of these infectious diseases
some other times
when we as a standard of care test for
vaccine related serologies in transplant
as we can see we do this a lot for our
kiddos
in our children's hospital you know
before they get a transplant or if they
have
if uh anybody has an autoimmune disease
and they're about to go on like long
immune suppression
we want to make sure that they have uh
sufficient titres to keep them protected
for the rest of their life against these
vaccine preventable diseases
and sarcophagi will likely be no
different a couple of things that we're
seeing that are a little bit different
so uh not everyone can produce
a sufficient response to vaccines to be
fully protected
that's particularly the case for people
who have
issues with their immune system so we
are seeing some
uh care uh care providers
um so if if you have an elderly relative
that's living with you that you must
care for
um that these people are wanting and
needing to have
their uh titers checked so to make sure
that they are protecting
the elderly person or the other
otherwise they need this regulated
person that they live with
um because they will be their primary
points of contact and then
kind of uh this unique thing that we're
seeing with um
coping 19 is that we also have what i
call psychological testing so
there's been a lot of anxiety around
program 19 and
understanding that your body has
produced antibodies and
is therefore somewhat protected against
copic
uh 19 is a psychological food to many
people so we are seeing people that are
coming in and just
want to have their titters checked and i
think we'll continue seeing some
some level of that happening as well but
we still have a lot to learn
as as is always the case um one of the
things we're looking at are really
trying to nail down some immunity
surrogates and things that are easily
measurable that indicate immunity
trying to understand how long immunity
will last uh
understanding the pediatric immune
response there's still so much that we
don't understand about that
um through prevalent studies are
underway uh there are a lot of
limitations to those
again as the vaccine has has come out um
and we talked about many of the antigens
overlap
and so if you're trying to to figure out
if your healthcare workers have been
exposed but they've also already been
vaccinated
we need ways to be able to tease out
vaccine versus natural disease exposure
and there are some special populations
that we should consider
again because pediatrics has a
differential immune response
looking at zero prevalence for them can
often be difficult and then
really also trying to come up with some
markers for immunity for vaccine and
natural disease
so having all of this happening uh in
our hospital
we wanted to assess a way that we could
look at
both vaccine and natural disease uh
immunologic response and so
the multiplex assay from bio-rad against
sarsko v2 igg was very attractive for
that reason
and we did an initial validation of it
using three different cohorts of samples
which we had available to us to see if
this would meet our clinical needs
so we did um we had already a cohort of
comparison samples we had tested on six
other
emergency use authorization platforms
that
we had brought through the laboratory
and there were 298 specimens available
that cohort of specimens
included specificity cereal samples and
sensitivity samples
and then we also had samples which we
termed serial samples from patients who
had been admitted to the emergency
department and subsequently
uh kept as inpatient we were able to
keep those as remnants
and that allowed us to look at increases
in titers over time
to verify the semi-quantitative nature
of of the assay
and then we also had some routine run
specimens so these were specimens that
came in
they had sarge kov2 antibodies ordered
as part of their clinical
care and that allowed us to assess a
larger number of sensitivity as well as
samples as well as general concordance
so the assays that we had
available in house the bio-rad essay
which looks at
four antigens rbd s1s2 and nucleotide
following that we had three we have
three rbd
acids we have uh the bachmann assay
which is specifically against igg
the siemens ace for the centaur and the
vista the cove2t assays are both total
antibody assays again against rbd
uh the euro immune elizas which were
some of the first um
that have come off that came on the
market so there is a lot of literature
for us to compare to we have both their
igg and iga which were manualizers
against the cyclone subunit
and then the only other nucleotide which
we had besides the biret is
the roche alexis and they start cooling
two acid
uh again being a nucleotide for total
antibodies
when we looked at specificity we had 170
specimens that we
that were enriched for autoimmunity as
well as other infectious diseases as you
can see here to the left
of note rbpe is kind of a non-standard
abbreviation
that is our respiratory viral panel
which is actually done from an np swab
uh and all of these samples were
collected uh
before stars kobe 2 was geographically
present
in the area of the university of
pittsburgh medical center but it was
present in the u.s
um and as you can see we had 100
specificity for both spike 2 and
nucleotide igg
and we had one cross-reactive sample for
rbd and spike 1
s1 giving us 99.4 specificity
that particular sample for rbpe was
positive for the common coronaviruses
and was actually reacted by three of our
six other assays so we do have a
suspicion that this could
be um a true positive there was no pcr
available at the time that these
you know these samples were being
collected so there's no real way for us
to tell
um however site 2 and nucleotides that
are actually the areas that have
the highest level of conservation with
uh the common coronaviruses our
obedience psych 1 actually has very
little um
conserved sequence with the common
coronaviruses which further makes us
think that this
this could uh not be possible today but
actually be true productivity
uh when we looked at sensitivity uh this
is a little bit busy if you look on the
the y-axis you'll see uh rbd nucleic
acid
s1 and s2 units per ml have been uh
assessed in a logarithmic scale so that
we can actually see the resolution a bit
better
and then base term symptom onset are
along the x-axis uh
when symptom onset was either unclear
asymptomatic
or they had say copd which is always
systematic
um we used pcr instead of base from
system onset
and what you can see is that rbd and s1
reflect
their sensitivity reflects each other
quite a bit um you can see the zero
conversion happening in the first 14
days
uh quite well for rbd and s1 with a bit
of a lag permissible
and as if you actually see many of the
ones never produced antibodies to s2 by
this assay
if we look at the later time points
greater than 30 days which it becomes
very important for our assessment of
convalescent plasma and
pseudo-prevalent studies you can see
that rbd nucleotide and s1 all do a
reasonable job
of having appropriate sensitivity for
prior infection
next we looked at the qualitative
positive agreement between assays
so you can see all of the assays listed
here to the left um
and it's again the platforms that we
previously discussed and then the last
row or rows um are actually the clinical
status
so the column the first column that
indicates overall concordance or
agreement
is if any of the four multiplex antigens
are positive then it's considered
positive and that's how we did overall
agreement there you can see that if we
look at the overall agreement for all
specimens percentages are quite high
they're greater than
um 94
for everything except for your immune
iga which is the only activity that
specifically detects iga
there is very high there are very high
levels of concordance between the assays
that detect rbd and spike one
in particular uh and interestingly when
we look at the clinical correlations um
so for specimens that were pcr positive
um for
greater than 14 days uh when we look at
the overall performance of all four of
the antigens together we actually get
100
uh agreement and the same thing for
clinical diagnosis
being positive at greater than 14 days
uh we have 100
concordance with 44 and 59 samples
respectively that was something we
didn't reach with any of the other
platforms
that we tested so that was very exciting
for us
um lastly looking at serial conversion
so again
this is indicative of the
semi-quantitative nature of the assay
uh what you can see in red is um the
bio-rad rbd and spike
one igg assay in blue are all of the
other assays that look at rbd and spike
one and you can see that all of those
trends together
and they all actually have
semi-quantitative performance uh in
green you can see the nucleus happens
that athletes
and those assays don't always trend
together um
and they do not always appear to be
semi-quantitative
particularly in the sixth patient uh
it's unclear if there is actually uh
an increase over time in the there's an
increase in overtime so
semi-quantitative for the bio-rad estate
the rochester appears to be level so
it's unclear if that is
simply an increased level of
detectability in
in that specimen or if it is not truly
semi-quantitative
um it is not currently approved as a
semi-quantitative option
so wrapping it up it uh this essay
appeared to be comparable to
existing um ce march as well as eua
serologic acids that we had tested in
our laboratory
um for us it was very important that it
be able to measure multiple analytes
simultaneously
um for the complex clinical
presentations that we see come through
as well as for epidemiologic research so
that we can differentiate between
natural disease
as well as the currently eua approved
vaccines
decisions regarding infection prevention
this has also been very helpful
for for that and then um we are also
always looking for surrogate markers for
immunity and we look forward to having
more data so that we can uh establish
these surrogate markers for community uh
in closing i'd like to recognize dr
michael sherin who was
my co-director for all of these studies
and the great team at upmc
um that helped us get all of this
together and um
we did have some help from bio-red in
the sample testing uh which was
super helpful for so many samples and
this was partially funded by viral
laboratories
with that i would like to turn this over
to dr lucy thank you
hello everybody and thank you so much dr
wheeler this is an exciting
topic and i look forward to share our
studies with you so what we did in a
laboratory
was using the bioplex 2200
starscope 2 igg panel to
figure out the performance and our goal
was to investigate the presence of the
sars cup to igg antibodies
using the bioplex 2200 igg panel in a
different population than those
used for the assay development
so the bioplex 2200 cyroscop2itg panel
detects igg antibodies
against the four different regions of
the virus
nucleocapsid the spike 1 and 2
and the receptor binding domain
on this presentation i'm going to
describe the protocol share with you
our results and the conclusions of the
study
so what we did is we tested frozen
remnant serum specimens
in three different patient populations
or cohorts
one of them was a a
241 cup two pcr positive patients
that we use for our percent
positive agreement calculations
another cohort of cadre and 60
cup 2 pcr negative patients
that we use for the percent negative
agreement
and then finally is it a set
10 sets of a specimens collected from
patients
tested for sars cup to ypcr
in general included at least two to six
consecutive collections
that we use to capture zero conversion
all these specimens were obtained
following central irb
approval and we're re-identified
but information on age gender and pcr
testing results
was available we follow manufacturer's
instructions on the viaplex 2200.
the demographic description of the
patient population that we use is shown
in this table
where we can see that the 240
specimens that were called pcr-positive
were composed of 103
female subjects averaging
an age with a mean age of 57.
57.7 years a male
population of 133
subjects with a mean age of 56.2
and then we had five unidentified gender
individuals in this group
the negative cohort was composed of 100
females
with a mean age of 50 years of age
and a group of 60 males
finally the longitudinal set contain
4 female subjects and 6 male subjects
of ages 62.9
and 72.2 as mean
so when we calculated the percent
agreement
with the star scope 2 pcr result or in
comparison with the sars code 2 pcr
results
we divided the data two major groups
the calculation for the
positive agreement and the calculation
for the negative agreement
the positive cohort consisted of 241
serum specimen
and in the top of this table in the
slides
you can see how we basically
look at the results by dividing
the time or a time frame in which
the specimens were obtained
in relationship when the
pcr was first positive or the virus was
first detected
so we we know based on the literature
that in general the antibodies can be
detected somewhere between 7 and 15 days
so we created three different time
frames
less or equal than seven days between
eight to 15 days
and somewhere between 16 and 45 days
what we were able to calculate
or find out is that the percent
positive agreement for those three time
frames
were 62 88 and 100
respectively for the 7 8 to 15
and 16 for 45 days time frames
the percent negative agreement is shown
at the bottom of the slide
and is 97.5 percent
and it was obtained by looking at the
cyroscope to igg panel results
in the negative cyroscope 2 bcr cohort
we also look at the sars cup to igg
panel results
distribution for each of the time frames
used to calculate the percent positive
agreement
this bar graph shows the number of
positive
and negative serology specimens
in the pcr positive cohort classified by
the
same time frames as the ones used to
calculate the positive
the percent positive agreement
we learned that most of specimens tested
by the cyroscope to igg panel were
collected during the first
seven days of detecting the virus
so this group made the 80 percent of all
the 241 pcr positive cohort
subjects while 11
and 9 were collected at 8
to 15 or after 16 days
respectively this observation may
explain
why we see a bit lower percent positive
agreement
in the styroscope to positive pcr cohort
that others that have been published
one of the the areas that were very
interesting to
um to look into where the longitudinal
cohort
and in this case i'm going to show you
two examples
of two different patterns that we
observe
so in this slide you can see patient
one zero two two three and uh
the progressive concentration of
antibodies that we detected
uh using the panel and uh
basically we wanted to be able to
demonstrate that the bioplex 2200
starscope to igg panel is sensitive
enough to be able to detect the serum
conversion so we analyze
several longitudinal patients
in this example the antibodies as you
can see
remains below the 10 units per ml
threshold that is shown here with the
dash
red line on days 1 and 2
after the detection of the virus in the
next
time frame or time points that i'm
showing in this graph
you can see the concentration of the
antibodies is already
elevated um showing a zero conversion
so on days 35
on day 36 you see that concentration
um being well above the threshold
and interestingly in this patient all
the antibodies
are elevated
in the in the same pattern
what i think is interesting and that's
why i show you this
next um example of a serial conversion
is that sometimes you may see different
patterns
and in this particular case patient one
zero two three eight uh doesn't
show an increase on the nucleocapsid
concentration so that will be
your gray line here
so rbd s1 and s2
are increased after
day 20 and remains increased for
several days but the nucleocapsid
antibody is never
going above the 10 units per ml
threshold
so what we concluded from the study is
that the analytical performance
comparable with other vendors is
very similar but
this panel provides more information
about the type of antibody
present so we concluded that 88
positive agreement after seven days
um was seen percent
after 15 days of deposit covered pcr
results
the negative agreement was 97.5
and overall this panel is an excellent
tool to monitor serial conversion
and identify antibody type without
having to set up multiple assays
so i like to acknowledge my colleagues
gage foster rebecca smith
leliana talamontes and dr gravy david
grenache
from trico research institute and
ebony jones from bio-rad
now i'm going to leave you with edward
gribby
thank you so much
thank you dr lucy um my name is edward
greber
and i will be talking about the a
comparative evaluation
of 21 high throughput commercially
available south korea to
serologic assays with a particular focus
on zero surveillance applications
um on this slide we we summarize
a a number of different use cases for
serological assays
these include diagnostic applications
um characterizing the persistence or
breadth of humeral immunity after
infection and after vaccination
detection of re-infections in other
words detecting
animalistic boosting of antibodies
section of
vaccine breakthrough infections and and
things like
increasingly possible two serotype
infections with responses to infections
with variants of concern
but the primary focus will be on
serous surveillance to estimate
cumulative size curvy to infection rates
or attack rates in populations
a key element of that is discriminating
vaccine-induced sero-positivity from
natural infection in the united states
where all
available vaccines are spike based that
can be done by combining an
anti-spike and anti-nuclear capsule
assay
but in some other contexts whole
inactivated virus vaccines are in use
and the problem is a little bit harder
to solve
on this slide we provide a matrix it's a
little bit too detailed
to talk through in detail but
um essentially identifying the key
performance characteristics for
different applications
and so for the zero surveillance
application we care
greatly about the sensitivity and
specificity of the assay
but we also want stable antibody
detection over time
now many assays particularly igg
assays as opposed to the
total immunoglobulin
antigen sandwich format assets show
rapid waning of reactivity
post infection and that's a problem for
estimating cumulative attack rates
we also care about reproducibility but
not so much quantitative reproducibility
for the serious surveillance application
um elements
like a broad dynamic range which may
include
the capability of performing on-board
dilutions
on the platform and quantitative
reproducibility matter for some of these
other more specialized applications
of detecting an amnestic boosting and so
forth
on this slide we provide links to a
number of resources that summarize these
different use cases and some of the
performance characteristics
that are relevant one important resource
i want to point out is the
fda's list of serologic assets that have
received emergency use authorization
the united states so this particular
study is part of a large cdc funded
program
um primarily monitoring
science kobe to stir prevalence in blood
donors
in more than 60 locations in the united
states
but the first aim of it was to evaluate
assays that could be used in serous
surveillance
and those are the results that we're
reporting
on today this slide again is too busy to
read really but
summarizes some characteristics of the
asset included in the study and
keep key points here are that there are
multiple formats
and the two primary ones are either
detection of a specific
immunoglobulin class like igg iga or igm
or these um antigen sandwich type
formats or total immunoglobulin
uh detection asses and and those
character
those formats become relevant for for
some of the
performance characteristics also
antibodies
to multiple antigens are detected
generally
either regions of the spike protein like
the receptor binding domain or
s1 s2 and antibodies
to nucleocapsid
the panel used in this evaluation had a
number of components
including a an unselected
cross-sectional
sample of covert 19 convolution plasma
donations a longitudinal series
with 24 donors followed followed up over
about 14 months with up to 14 serial
time points
um a single serial conversion panel
blinded replicates for reproducibility
analyses
a serial dilution theory series um
a purposely selected set of uh so-called
sierra silent cases so these are
qualified ccp donors who nevertheless
are negative to anti-south korea to
antibodies
and then a significant number of
pre-covert 19 negative controls for
estimating specificity
but getting into the performance
characteristics of the assets
um for sensitivity for estimating
sensitivity we have a bit of a problem
because we don't have a true gold
standard
available to us here like documented
dates of pcr confirmed
infection however in the sensitivity
analysis donors
did qualify as ccp donors
which means they provided evidence of
diagnosed in prior infection
uh that was resolved at the time of
first donation
uh but because of this absence of a true
gold standard we
did we three different analyses one
where we defined true positivity as
reactivity on at least three binding
antibody assays
secondary analysis that defined as
positivity
any neutralizing activity as determined
by the broad institute's
live virus plug reduction neutralization
assay
and also an analysis based simply on
qualifying as a tcp donation
specificity is based on the negative
controls
uh so the the primary sensitivity
analysis
shows that uh most of the evaluated
assays
um have very good sensitivity but there
are some exceptions
where the sensitivity is significantly
poorer so they're grouped here
with the total ig acids on the left
then the igg acid then the single iga
sn1
igg igm combination multiplexed assay
to the right the color coding indicates
the antigen targets so
anti-spike assays in red
anti-nuclear capsule acids in
green and then the small number of
multi-antigen
assays indicated in blue and so here we
can see that most of these assets do
have sensitivity above 95 percent
but some like the the simmons igg
s1 rbd assay and the beckmann quilter
igg s1 rbd assay and a couple of others
have significantly
lower sensitivity than average
in this group and this includes the
the single ig asa that had rather poor
sensitivity uh perhaps not unexpectedly
um i'll just quickly move through the
secondary sensitivity analyses
um even when we um
compare essentially to the presence of
neutralization activity the pattern is
very similar
the same asset with lower sensitivity on
the primary definition
show poorer sensitivity using this
definition
and the pattern is also repeated with
the
more liberal definition of positivity
based on qualifying as a ccp donor
when we look at specificity note that
the scale is very different here
and what we're really looking for here
is specificity in excess of 99
so again most of the um
high throughput assets developed by
major manufacturers
um do have a specificity
greater than 99.5 percent
in this which includes the roche and the
two
roche total ig assets the ortho
total ig assay and the bi-rad bacteria
nuclear capsule
assay as well as the various
of the igg acids have very good
specificity including the
bio-red bioplex multiplexed
iggs that
has four analytes corresponding to four
antigens which in fact has a perfect
specificity in this panel
moving on to repeatability and precision
we had some trouble coming up with a
with a good metric
of quantitative repeatability um that
could be summarized easily
and what we settled on is the so-called
inter-class correlation coefficient so
this is based on
uh 15 samples that were tested
in six replicates each with testing labs
blinded
to those replicas so they did not know
which
samples were aliquots of the same root
specimen and what we see here that most
assets
in the study actually have iccs uh
well in excess of 0.9 um
or rather in the region of 0.9 or in
excess of 0.9 which is the conventional
threshold for excellent repeatability
um the line
at 0.75 indicates the conventional
threshold for good
repeatability and there's only one essay
in this set which is the one thai assay
where the um icc was uh
below 0.75 and that we would
characterize as possibly
inadequate quantitative reproducibility
i will avoid
explaining the concept of the icc in too
much detail in the interests
of time but it essentially
measures the proportion
of the variation across those 90 samples
tested that comes from between sample
variability and so a perfect asset would
always return the same result on the
same sample and a hundred percent
of the variation would come from between
sample variability
uh this slide here shows um coefficients
of variation
uh for all 15 of those replica tested
samples for each of the assays
and this is provided really for
reference purposes
moving to dilutional performance which
is only relevant
in some niche applications
for that reason i will only show some
examples and not
the analysis for for each of the assets
included in the study
um but but really the key message here
is that some
essays and one example is the
orthovitrous total ig
and the spike assay that is the primary
screening assay
in the mass bd serous surveillance
program
really has very good linear dilutional
response
throughout the the range of reactivities
um in these plots where we are we are
plotting the expected reactivity against
the observed
reactivity the expected reactivity is
defined
by replicate testing of the neat
samples there are five of them there by
definition on the
diagonal line so you'll see them in the
top right corner
and dividing that average reactivity
over five repeats
by the dilution factor gives us the
expected reactivity
and so perfect performance here would be
all of the colored
dots being on that diagonal line as well
and what we notice is that assets with
very broad dynamic range
um tend to have a good linear response
including below the asset
cut off for positive for for positivity
or reactivity
um but what is what is more typical
even in relatively high dynamic range
assays is that there's
uh a linear response in the region of
the cut-off
above the cut-off and a little bit below
the cut-off and then a flattening out
where that linear response breaks down
indicating that if you
were trying to quantify reactivity and
very at
very low reactivity levels um
there's a natural boundary to how far
you can take that
um and and here we see uh on two
analytes
um of the of the bioplex multiplexed
assay the same pattern
a linear response including below the
asset cut off
um better flattening out at a certain
level
which would be the the the level at
which you would
stop uh interpreting um dilutional data
characterizing low level reactivity um
now critical component of this study is
to
characterize assets in terms of um the
durability of antibody detection over
time
so i won't say too much about the
methods except to say that
our primary primary analysis is based on
linear mixed effects regression models
in which they are donor specific
intercepts
and um
slopes but also population average and
intercept and slope and so what we'll be
reporting here
are the are the the average slopes
um to determine whether an assay shows
rapid raining or not
and we're also able to calculate half
essay signal half-lives
based on this based on a very similar
regression analysis
just by way of comparison these are
neutralizing titus over time
by various neutralizing antibody
titration assays
so those do decline over time um
and here are some examples of
assay signal over time now we've scaled
all of these
to render the the slope estimates uh
comparable with one another so these are
plotted over the same range
but you can see quite variable patterns
with with some assays um
shrink what stable response and if we go
on to the next slide we'll see some
assets that do show
a pretty rapid um
[Music]
waning over time each colored line here
represents
one of the 24 donors in the longitudinal
series that
informs this analysis so summarizing
that information based on the
slopes from the regression modeling
we notice that the um antigen sandwich
total ig format assay tend to have
stable reactivity over time
uh in fact the only ones in that group
where we can distinguish the slope from
zero
um we in fact see uh increasing
reactivity over time with the
ortho total ig assay um
most of the igg assays um and
and here i should point out that the
bioplex acid individual analytes
are plotted separately um
most of them show raining over time but
at different rates and the
antinuclear capsule igg assets tend to
wear and faster
than the um anti-spite
nuclear capsule sorry anti-spike igg
assays
um and and the key point here with
respect to the
the bioplex is that while most of the
analytes do show waning there's
one that where we cannot distinguish the
slope
from zero and so the overall
interpretive value
of that assay is likely to remain stable
over time at least over this time scale
of approximately four months
this slide just shows the slopes in
comparison to those
of neutralizing titers on the right hand
side
and this slide shows for those assays or
analytes where we do see
rapid waning the estimated half-lives
that range from about 40 days to about a
100 days a little bit
but more than 100 days and so pretty
pretty rapid
waning many of these assays
we did further regression analysis to
determine
where the assay format or antigen target
matters most and what we find is that
both matter
and so even in multivariable models both
are significant
and have an impact on whether the
the assay shows waning and how rapid
that waning is
i won't say very much about the relative
timing of sierra conversion this is a
very busy plot
with assay signal rescaled and so that
zero
is the cutoff for positivity
and what we observe here is that most of
the assets in the study
show zero conversion over approximately
the same
time scale with a couple of exceptions
there are a few that are slightly
earlier
and a few though slightly later and
there's one where this donor
never showed never serial converts it
and there's also one where
we saw positivity very early on which is
clearly prior to infections taking place
and so that indicates a specificity
problem
if we look at the correlation of
signal with by with neutralization
titers
we see reasonably good correlation these
plots here
are for the assets included in the fda's
revised
convalescent plasma eua and
on this slide here we see similar plots
for the analytes on the
on the bioplex and we've derived here
cut offs
the various analytes of the bioplex
assay that
may work well for qualifying
ccp units as high quality units we also
performed
rock curve analyses which i
won't talk about in any great detail
except to show
that this is what they look like and if
we do that for all of the assays
and setting a standard of a
titer on the broad assay of at least
one to 250 we can derive
optimal thresholds on the binding assays
for predicting that um high
neutralizing tighter and achieve pretty
good sensitivity and specificity for
for that condition
i'll move on to my concluding slides
which really focuses on an assessment of
all of these assets
for specifically serious surveillance
applications i'll remind you
of the matrix i showed early on that
identified sensitivity specificity
stability of antibody detection and
qualitative reproducibility as key
characteristics
for
zero surveillance applications of these
assays note
that other applications um would have
different
desirable characteristics for example
you want
to have an assay that wanes roughly in
conjunction with
neutralizing antibody activity um
if you wish to use it to infer
something like immunity or vaccine
response
but for for estimating cumulative attack
rates
uh you want stability of antibody
detection um
and what we and one note here is that
the
the reproducibility assessment here is
is based on the
quantitative reproducibility which may
not be 100
appropriate for this application but
most assets perform well on that
and what we find is that there really
are five
standard essays here that show all four
characteristics that are
desirable for the zero-to-balance
application
and this includes both of the roche
total ig assets both the anti-spike and
the anti-nuclear capsule assay
the auto total ig and spike assay
um the bi-rad platealia nucleic and
total ig anti-nuclear capsule assay
and the bi-rad bioplex igg assay
and the reason it makes the cat
primarily is that
because of that one analyte the anti-s2
igg
that shows stability over time the
qualitative interpretation
appears to be stable over time and so it
also gets a green check mark in the
in the final column and then i would
like to just conclude
by pointing out that there are many
people who should be acknowledged
but i particularly want to call out mars
stone
and mike bush my very close
collaborators at vri
in conducting this study
thank you for your attention and we will
now move on to the question and
answers section portion of the session
thank you
wow thank you to all of our speakers for
their informative presentations
we are now going to start the live q a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
we already have some great questions in
coming in from the audience
so we're gonna start with this one dr
wheeler this one is for you
do the individual antibody marker levels
have
any clinical implications
hi uh yes uh we do see that there are
some clinical implications
as we covered some of the clinical
scenarios where we may
have a need for differential diagnosis
um looking at
a nucleotide antibody gives us more
information about exposure to sarcoleb2
where rbd um as a specific antigen
serology against rbd
has a better correlation with
neutralizing titers so both of those
have
a separate clinical utility for us um
it is important to recognize so that
these aren't standalone tests
that other testing uh is part of the
landscape of
being able to tease out some of these um
differential diagnoses particularly in
our immune suppressed
uh but vaccinated patients
great thank you so much dr wheeler um dr
gerber we're gonna go
go over to you now for this next
question do you feel that serology
assays
are sufficient to confidently identify
convalescent plasma donors
well thank you for that question it's an
important question
um the short answer is yes um the the
fda's
uh revised um convalescent plasma eua
does allow the use of binding antibody
assays to identify high titan units
and our assessment of the correlation of
binding antibody
signal intensity on serologic assays
with
neutralizing titers show that those
correlations are
sufficient to derive cut-offs on
binding antibody acids for detecting
or predicting high neutralizing
titers an important caveat
is that the thresholds
that we're able to detect can achieve
very high
specificity or negative percent
agreement
and very high positive predictive
values but they have relatively low
negative predictive values and so there
is a definite loss of true high tighter
units
that are not successfully identified
using binding antibody proxy signals
but the approach can accurately
classify units as high title units
great thank you so much for that answer
and it looks like we have time for just
one more question
so dr lucy we're gonna we're gonna turn
it over to you
what is the value of having multiple
antibody markers over
just a single marker
hello and thank you for the question
this is a
very interesting that body interested in
about
multi markers i think um
my my response is also in support of
what dr
wheeler just mentioned that in a multi
marker you're able to see
obviously the antibodies to um to the
different parts of the
the viral protein and
depending whether you're doing serial
surveillance
or you want to know vaccine status
or whether the patient has been exposed
to the cytoskeleton
viral particles is you need
and by having a multiplex assay
instead of having set up several
different vendors
you have everything in one single
instrumentation with
um one single run if you will so i think
there's a
double sided to my answer or or
different reasons to the answer one is
clinically what you're looking for and
practically
the practicality of having a multiplex
thank you thank you so much doc
thank you so much dr lucy for your
answer we want to again
thank all three of our speakers dr grebe
dr lucy and dr wheeler for their time
today
and for their important research we
would also like to thank labbert and our
sponsor
bio-red laboratories for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i would like to thank the
audience today for joining us
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us
and until next time bye bye everyone